This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, This is Chris Abraham
season five episode 37 of The
Chris Abraham Show.
This might be a 2 parter because
I might not get all of my.
Ideas out in the first one.
Or it just might be a short
show.
This is The Chris Abraham Show,
and today's episode is about the
inevitable liberal and
conservative pendulum that
everybody believes that they are
able to escape from, right?
There is always a belief that
the political system in America
or around the world will in the
past has gone kind of in a
pendulum between extreme left
and extreme right, and that this
is inevitable.
Recently though, there has been
a lot of energy spent on trying
to maintain.
A more leftist, more liberal,
more enlightened, sustained
swing to the left.
And The funny thing about it is,
as this belief is becoming more
and more fate to comply and more
and more assumed, the pressure
building up.
Because of unintended
consequences and because of
blowback, and because every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction.
The more assertion, the more
pressure, the more censorship,
the more controlled messaging,
the more aggressive support, the
more.
Revolutionary fervor.
The more extreme leftism, the
more openness with using words
that are generally historically
more associated with the things
that America is always bulked
at, such as Marxism, socialism,
communism.
These things are just.
Putting more pressure on a
veracity, A ferocious buildup of
pressure that will in fact
become an equal and opposite
pressure.
The further that the, the
further that the left pushes
the.
Natural cycle of the pendulum to
the left, the more assertive
that the right, which is a
majority in America, they
they've always had names for it.
They call it the moral majority
or they call which of course
makes you say but I'm not
immoral but compared to
traditional 5000 years of human
existence.
L GB TQIA plus is considered a
little unique, and while one
might say that in quote UN quote
tribal societies, there is
always some, you know 2 spirit,
generally speaking the two
spiritness in a tribe is a is a
rarity and is not normalized.
It's a It's a rare.
Holy position rather than an
entire tribe being, I don't know
some variation of non binary or
queer.
So based on that I'm always
afraid.
I'm very gay friendly.
I hope everybody is able to let
their true self show beautifully
into the world, but my fear is
always.
And I was watching a a trans
woman in a show yesterday, and
I'll try to link to it.
She's afraid that she's a pygmy
girl.
She's afraid that she might be
the kind of trans woman that
people like me can understand.
And her premise was that there
is right now.
What is happening now is a
divorce.
That's happening between the LGB
and the TQIA because the LGB is
a sexuality or a sexual
preference and the TQIA plus are
gender identities and neither
the twain shall meet.
Even the lesbian, gay and
bisexuals in this case was
mostly gay men.
We're saying that the sick that
the gender identities are not
real, which I feel like are
fighting words to people who
believe that they were born as
non binary or as the opposite
sex when they were born and that
gender is a construct.
I believe that having gay men
say that.
Their reality isn't a real
reality is probably, and I hate
this word, problematic, so I
will share the video, but it's
very interesting because at the
end of the video she's like,
I've spent the last 10 years and
this is kind of paraphrasing
her, she said.
I've been spending the last 10
years, 12 years, 10 years trying
to tell you to kind of chill
out.
And not be so extreme that this
is going to instigate or
catalyze a reaction by the
reactionary right, and that the
pendulum is so far left now that
there is going to be inevitable
blowback.
Not just feedback, but blowback
and her belief.
Is that this is going to result
in a lot of homophobia.
Not only transphobia, but
homophobia.
And that ten years ago, 20 years
ago, when it went from Don't
Ask, Don't Tell, to normalized
gay marriage and normalized gay
services and normalized gay
partnership and normalized.
Gay taxes and normalized gay
work coverage and things like
life insurance and health
insurance and all these kinds of
umbrella services that straight
couples and straight
partnerships have historically
had.
Cisgender, straight, etcetera.
Her belief is that the.
The community.
And she says that's also a
problematic phrase because it's
not a community.
What it is, is it's an it's an
alliance of people who are
trying to fight phobia.
So it's it's an alliance, not a
community.
Her belief is that this blowback
is going to result in in
legislations and violence.
And reconsideration of decisions
that were made a decade ago.
Because from because there's
going to be a reaction, a
reaction to reaction to things
that seem more dangerous than
normalized, for example, the
groomer concept, right?
You can't just say.
There are more groomers in the
Catholic Church and the
religious space, or in the the
the scouts or whatever.
You can't say there are more
groomers, which is to say
pedophiles in the straight
community, than there are in the
L GB TQIA community.
And make that be all right once.
Once the right starts perceiving
as the L GB TQIA community as
being threatening to them and
not just integrated with them,
you know it comes down to pick
me right.
This is all about you deserve
the rights that I have, but not
one right more.
Now that the LGBTQIA community
is being treated like a
protected class or a protected
species that makes the cisgender
white straight communities feel
like they are lesser than.
Upon the fact that there are
videos of people saying we will
take your children and we will,
we will convert your children
and we will make your children
nonbinary, we will trans them,
etcetera.
It doesn't matter what the truth
is.
It's only matters what people
perceives perceive and if this
becomes a panic, if this becomes
an anti.
Nobody's going to admit to being
anti trans, but you can see
every day that straight men are
saying I will, I'm not
interested.
I'm not interested in dating,
quote UN quote.
I'm not interested in dating an
ugly woman or a fat woman or a
tall woman or a flat woman.
What makes you think that I'm
willing to date a trans woman?
All of these kind of things.
If you start making a silent
majority or a moral majority
start to feel like they are
under threat and they are not,
you know, you they're not
generously in some sort of
noblesse oblige, noblesse oblige
kind of giving, sharing, and
accepting a community into
theirs.
As opposed to a rigorous and
vigorous separation and
resentment and hatred and
outward hatred for everything
that assists, everything that is
straight, everything that is
square, everything that is quote
normal.
And when you start exposing a
type of sexuality, a type of
evangelism, a type of.
Promotion, you know, when it
goes from what happens in my
bedroom is my business to do not
prevent me from exploring my own
sexuality, my own identity, in
public, wherever I want.
Or bringing into the classroom
or sexualizing children when
they were the perception of
sexualizing or genderizing
children when they're under 18
and someone else's children.
All these things are going to
have rigorous, vigorous and
violent blowback and.
This particular trans woman on
the the, on the YouTube, on
YouTube did an amazing job of
arguing that she didn't argue
and he's anything that was anti
trans, anything that was
anti-gay.
She was just saying that.
And you know, this is a.
This is, you know, a traditional
trope, which is to say if you
turn the heat up on the pan full
of frogs too high, the frogs
will jump from the pan.
And it's really important when
you do cultural revolutions
unless you rely on on literal
violence in camps.
And a real revolution where
people are put into camps and
they're put into gulags and if
they are not flexible, they are
they are removed or killed or or
you know, brainwashed or
whatever.
Like if you want to do a hearts
and minds conversion where
overtime people come become more
and more normalized to what have
been traditionally counter
cultural norms and values.
Then you need the frogs to
normalize to the change in heat
in the pan without encouraging
them to jump out.
And by analogy, jumping out in
essence means start to be
violent.
It's against the L GB TQIA
community, which will be hereby
taken as a lump.
So it will blow back not only on
transphobia, but because the
entire thing is an alliance.
You know the action of Japan
will have or bricks.
Let's use bricks, Brazil.
You know, Russia, India, China,
South Africa.
The action of of of Russia will
flow into the reputation of all
the other places.
If if India gets into a war with
Pakistan, then there will be
consequences for Brazil, Russia,
China and South Africa.
So when you are in a strict
alliance, when you are an L GB
TQIA plus.
It's all or nothing, right?
It So if the blowback, you know
that's happening already with
regards to Roe V Wade, right,
that was that could have been
something that was pushed too
far, too fast.
It seemed like, you know,
America was perfectly fine with
the way things were set up.
We're very pro, personal choice,
pro independence.
If it's in my body, it's me kind
of culture.
And you know, the more pressure,
the more, you know, people were,
you know, the religious right
was hearing things about full
term abortions, abortions after
the baby was delivered, all
kinds of crazy.
Things that they associate with
eugenics, or with blood
sacrifice, or with sacrifice to
ball, or with Lucifarianism or
with Satanism or with anti life
or with degeneracy.
And here we have that word
degeneracy now.
When the normalization of less
gay, lesbian, and bisexuals into
their ability to have legally
sanctioned by the state, by
this, by the country, by
companies, by HR, by the
military, and so forth, the
normalization of this means that
the perception of a threat level
is 0.
The moment that there's a
perceived perception that the
entire like this was a complete
it was a complete trap, It was a
bait and switch.
There was a you were pretending
to be normal people who just
happened to love other people of
your same sex.
Because love is love.
Into a an active movement of
degeneracy, right?
Like if the if the if the right
starts perceiving the entire
leftist culture as a giant fuck
fast.
Like, you know, like like
happens during Burning Burning
Man or the Rainbow festivals or
or if it if it's, you know,
fearlessly and shamelessly.
Chaps bare butts, Bare bodies in
the Pride parade.
If it becomes something that
people are conspiring to do
against your children, or trying
to do against the children's
will, or if there's anything on
TikTok about.
You know, I'm a teacher.
I have an opportunity to
disabuse these children of their
patriarch, their patriarchy or
their capitalism or their
traditionalism.
Disabuse them of their belief in
God.
Disabuse them of their belief
in.
One boy, one girl.
Boys love girls, girls love
boys, Boys get married to girls
and have babies.
To disabuse them of that right?
Like things like the libs of
TikTok and what is a woman and
associations with the LBG,
LGBTQI A with pedophilia or
grooming children this is.
And the fact that this has been
pushed away for at least five
years, I mean honestly once
children were home and using
Zoom to get their schooling and
once people started listening in
on some some school videos and
realize streaming webcams and
realizing that the that the that
the textbooks in their
perception.
I'm an only child who has no
wife, has no kids, has no
connection to public education.
I'm just saying the the chatter
that's coming to my ears is
there is this perception that
nobody knew what was going on
until they could listen in on
the webcams.
And the fact that it seemed to
me, in my perception of the
chatter that.
Teachers were saying that
parents were prohibited to
listen in on what was going on
in the schools, but of course
that just makes parents want to
record everything even more.
And the fact that people were
responding negatively to how
much people were freaking out
when the Libs of TikTok were
sharing things that they didn't
steal off of a hard drive that
they just found on their own,
publicly posted in spaces like
YouTube, TikTok stories, et
cetera.
This is an inevitable,
inevitable powder keg that's
going to explode.
And I do not want a world where
there is active homophobia.
I'm like, I mean active like
kinetic homophobia.
Kinetic Transphobia, Kinetic
anti black racism, Kinetic anti
foreigner racism.
I do not want all of these anti
transphobia, anti homophobia,
anti racist revolutions to end
up getting the complete
smackdown of a bully that's 10
times your size.
Like not ten times but 246810
like 5 times your size.
Like in many cases the enemy if
you will is 70 to 80% of the
population really.
Jewish communities, black
communities, gay communities,
trans communities, non binary
communities.
While the numbers are growing
and you and the community is
enjoying a popularity where you
know people are, it's become
extremely trendy, right?
Like recently on Breaking
Points, I heard that between 30
and 50% of all Ivy League school
students identify as gay or
trans, right?
So there's a huge number of
people in these elite
universities.
But also remember that not that
many Americans go to college and
very, very few of them go to Ivy
League universities.
And I dare say, since the fact
that, you know, the joke is, is
that all college girls tried
lesbianism during college,
right?
The joke is, is I was gay at
Smith, I was gay at Yale, I was
gay at Harvard.
So try experimenting with
sexuality and desire and
lesbianism and bisexuality and
so forth is a trope.
It's a common trope.
It's not invented.
There's a tendency for, for, for
experimentation in a safe
environment to be something that
people do, even if it's in their
heart of hearts.
Like, let's say that when you
try out lesbianism or try out
bisexuality in college or in in
in, in K through 12, that might
always be a part of you, right?
You might look back at that, you
know, because you're so cool and
so enlightened with great
fondness and great openness.
And but you might decide that
you want to have a family and
that you want to have kids and
that you are going to gulp
suffer the fact that men are
awful, disgusting, smelly and
selfish and you were going to
make a life with a husband to
the best of your ability, right.
So the way people act and the
way they believe are oftentimes
different.
But it is completely common that
people identify as being
bisexual, lesbian or gay during
their time of exploration and
experimentalism while they are
at an Ivy League elite
university, one of the Seven
brothers of the Seven Sisters.
So that's not new.
I'm just afraid about the
blowback, right?
There's a bully in the room who
has, whether he admits it to
himself or herself or not, has
been grandiose, has accepted you
into their country, right.
It might not be what you like,
but you were allowed to be equal
and not just a freak.
So now there's this belief that
there's this 20% of the
population is saying, OK, thanks
for allowing us to be normal
like you by the way.
You're not normal.
You're racist.
You're sexist.
You're capitalist.
You are cristo fascist.
You are killing you.
You are killing children by not
allowing them or wanting them to
transition.
You are killing women and girls
by not allowing them to or not
wanting them to get at will,
abortion and so forth.
And all of these like this
result said, wait, who The Who
the hell are you?
I'm the person who is so, so
grandiose as to allow you as to
stop bullying you.
WTF are you doing trying to
cancel me?
I, in the 80s and 90s decided to
stop canceling you and allow you
to go ahead and be who you are
and experience your own.
Love is love.
And now you're telling me I
don't have the ability to be who
I am?
Let me show you how big I am.
Let me show you how big my
church is.
heteronormative world is.
Let me show you how many white
people there actually are in
this country.
And that what happens if we do
not explore the noble obligation
of being good to our neighbors
and if we give you a little bit
of shitcanning.
And that's what I'm afraid of.
And that's what the YouTuber
trans woman is afraid of two.
And she seems to believe that
this blowback is happening now
and that it is going to get
pretty ugly and that she doesn't
know what to do and that she's
trying to, she said what should
happen is finding a way of
taking L GB TQIA and doing an
audit and auditing out all of
the perceived grooming attention
to children, attention to K
through 12.
And like any heteronormative
normie, you you're not allowed
to touch a girl who's under 18.
And generally speaking, you
shouldn't really touch a girl
who's less than 10 years your
junior.
So there is, she says that the
only way that this is going to
be abated and to calm down is if
there's a rigorous D quote,
quote delausing of groomers and
pedophiles from the L GB, TQIA
world.
We see how the Catholic Church
and their unwillingness to
actively delouse the Catholic
Church and disabuse them of all
of their pedophiles.
And you know what a pedophile
does?
A pedophile goes to where the
children are, right?
So if you are a pedophile, you
will become a Scout master, or
you will become a parish priest,
or you will become a school
teacher, or you will become,
etc.
Maybe you'll become a what is it
called the kind of doctors that
pediatrician, Right.
So they so like I don't know.
And of course this is going to
blowback on on on anti-Semitism
and this is going to blowback on
feminism and this is going to
blowback on socialism and this
is going to blowback on Marxism.
This is going to blowback on
Antifa and this is even going to
blowback on any self identified
trained Marxist associated black
activism as well.
And it's going to be really ugly
if it happens.
And I don't know how to prevent
it.
And I'm seeing it happen too.
So this is my prediction and
inshallah, I hope it doesn't
happen.
Because love is love.
And I grew up in Hawaii where we
used to call people who were
seconds to spirit or just gay or
lesbian or whatever.
There were a lot of trans
Hawaiians and they were called
mahu.
But mahu isn't like, you know,
the F word or you know anything
like that.
It's not like calling someone
FAG or FAGGOT like Mahu is
merely A descriptive thing.
Like I've asked all my friends
from Hawaii to make sure it's
not just a a Howley freaking
like guy from New York.
Even though I was there from 6
to 18, I wanted to make sure it
was a loving word and it is like
Mahu SEC 2 spirit or or trans or
whatever.
They were on palominos and major
parades and they were, they're
adored and they're accepted and
they're loved and they're part
of society and growing up and
you know, there's always been
lots of gay bars in Waikiki and
I'm sure elsewhere and lots of
gay clubs.
And it's always been a culture
that's been completely
normalized in Hawaii, nay.
So I don't want anybody to be
transphobic or or or or or a
homophobic or racist or sexist
or any of that stuff.
My dad, my mom trained.
My dad was a little bit
homophobic because he was a
pretty boy and he didn't like
male attention, but that I
recently realized how often my
mom must have thought I was gay
growing up.
Because years later when I was
an adult, she's like, it's not
that I have anything against
people being gay, but I was
really happy when you weren't
gay because I didn't want your
life to be harder than it would
be.
So I don't want anybody's mom to
tell them that they feel like
being gay, lesbian, trans and so
forth would result in a life of
suffering.
I want everybody's life to be as
as I want everybody's baseline,
to be as gentle and loving as
possible.
We're all chaotic people.
Each one of us are our own
biggest, our own biggest enemy.
But I don't want the external
world to look at you cross eyed.
So lots of love.
I hope that this all figures
itself out without any violence,
and I don't know what it's going
to look like.
Like the yeah, this, this whole
groomer thing has been the whole
like, you're converting all of
our babies to be to snip off
their genitals.
And all the other propaganda
that's happening is actually
really taking root and really
finding a grip and really
finding traction.
So there's a belief and it goes
all the way to oligarchs are all
child traffickers and and
adrenochrome and people are
drinking baby blood.
And if you kill a baby when it's
completely freaked out you can
extract this juice from it that
keeps you alive forever.
And then all the ball worship
and the Satanism, like once the
entire L GB TQIA community gets
rolled up and being a bunch of
demon humans that are all need
to be excised from the entire
community, that's dangerous
right?
So you don't become humans
anymore.
You become demons and and people
you know.
No matter how much you muck
people of faith, don't forget
that there are, there are what
is it?
There are Orthodox Jewish
communities that still believe
in you know, and and and demons
and and and and sin.
There are Christian communities
that still actually believe in
demons and the devil and the
spiritual war between good and
evil that are just going to
result in a in a in a judgment
day.
There are Muslims who are the
most believers in the entire
world.
I mean they believe, believe,
believe.
And I was talking to a friend
the other day and he said that
if he found out his son was gay,
he would kill him.
And I don't know whether that's
real kill or like figurative
kill, but if he found out that
anything like this was
happening, he said that he would
move his entire family back to
Albania.
So, so, like, don't get that
wrong.
Like, don't forget black
families are pretty antigay and
antitrans.
A lot of them are Christian and
antigay and antitrans.
There's still a DL culture
because a lot of black men and
black women, as well as working
class men and women and
certainly Latino and Latino and
Chicano men and women who need
to stay in the closet because
they're they're they're they're
evangelical, they're Baptists,
they're Catholic cultures.
Their families would, would,
would completely not be okay
with that.
So Muslim families aren't okay
with that Christian families.
Like like it's terrifying.
It's terrifying.
And I really didn't believe it
until I heard in 2023, you know,
an Albanian friend, literally.
You talk like that.
Like my parents, if I did come
out as gay.
And I'm sure that I was always
coming out as weird for them
because, like, I haven't dated
anybody, you know, since 2016,
right?
Like, I don't even like, I'm
just perfectly fine alone.
Like, that's going to be its own
weird sexuality.
They always knew I'm weird.
Everybody knows I'm weird.
I'm on the edge of queer.
I just don't have a
nontraditional sexuality.
I still like zaftig women who
are well above teenagers.
I don't even see what the appeal
is in teenagers.
They all look like daughters to
me.
They all look like nieces and I
feel very protective of them.
But you know, women in their 30s
and 40s, man all day long, so
that's not it.
But I'm happy, like to be as
homoerotic as possible.
My homoeroticism isn't physical,
though.
I'm happy always to tell my
friends that I love them and how
beautiful they look and how
gorgeous they look and all those
other things.
I'm not afraid of calling men
beautiful or sexy, even because
I have eyeballs and I'm not.
I'm never afraid of anybody
beating me up because honestly,
every all of my friends are more
spectrum enlightened younger
beings anyway.
So, and like I said, like
nobody's cared whether you're
gay or not in my urban world, my
urban world, you know, since the
80s.
Like my Buddy Miles came out to
me when he was 18.
He didn't come out in high
school.
We were, we were in high school
till 1988.
So like that, he didn't feel
comfortable with that.
But I wish he had.
But in my all boys Catholic
school we use the F word a lot.
The FAG, everybody called
everything FAG and that might
have been because a lot of
people called all boys, Catholic
school boys to be FAG's as well.
So I remember that when I was a
high school wrestler in an all
boys school, I know I got a lot
of like stink from the other
boys from other schools who
would wrestle us.
You know, they would make jokes
about you know, don't feel me up
and this is not, this is not a
make out sesh and all that other
kind of stuff.
So maybe that unintended
consequences, because you know,
even if you don't mean what you
say, if you use the FAG word as
a weapon, people who are gay,
lesbian, bi are going to feel
it's a hostile environment and
will keep their head down.
And I understand this idea that
it's really important not to
keep your head down, but like, I
don't know, I feel like I
understand that.
But you have to have risk
assessment, you have to have
risk mitigation.
And while your environment, your
cocoon, your community, your
space where you've moved to to
feel safe.
Your bars.
Your.
Your clubs, your.
Your choirs.
Your schools, your.
State, local government, Your
cities feel like completely safe
spaces.
Realize that it's still, in many
places. the United States, it's
still the 19th century.
In a lot of other places, it's
still the 50s and and a lot of
lot of places.
Right outside the Beltway, it's
still 1970s.
So I don't want all the frogs to
jump from the pan, is all I'm
saying.
And I love you guys.
I shared too much.
I'm probably mansplaining or my
voice is a cisgender 53 year old
white male isn't appreciated
because I have entitlement, I
have height entitlement, I have
pretty privilege, I have blah
blah blah and I get it.
So that's why only 12 people
listen to every episode.
Because my voice isn't
important, isn't necessary, and
has a million imitators, which
is great, because now I feel
open to share because nobody's
listening.
So it's a perfect feedback loop.
Again, I love you.
I love you no matter who you
are, who you love, what spirit
you are, whether you believe or
don't believe in a higher power,
what gender you perceive
yourself, what gender you are,
what gender you want to be,
whether you are identifying is
whatever.
I will always use your pronouns,
and if I don't, it's a mistake.
But I also feel like I need to
opt in on that.
And you can't make me.
You can't make me do anything
because I have my own agency and
I don't.
Even with my own agency, I don't
feel like I can tell you to do
anything.
So ergo, you can't tell me to do
I need to opt in and I need to
do things out of compassion and
love and not because I'm made
because that's where that's
where I jump out of the pan is
when there's strict enforcement.
I'm extremely anti that.
Anyway, I'll talk to you soon.
I hope you guys are well.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.